over a good steal
but to dribble that ball and hit the
three he thought about passing it so now
I'll dribble it instead beautiful let's
watch it here as Toliver kicks it out to
him he takes a look
that was just to get Fernandez first
could have been ahead by 30. yeah he
were very good offensively
hurry yeah
out of bounds play
I don't know whether LeBron touched the
ball there
so many problems winning here in Denver
yes 15 to the last 16. Steph Curry
Rainbow's in another
what a night for curry 36 points seven
assists seven rebounds hurry they're
gonna go quick hurry off the screen got
enough room
again butter Steph Curry his 11th three
of the night
Steph Curry with 54 points tops in the
NBA this season
[Applause]
line for the 14th four-point play in
these playoffs I mean when he got the
rebound he had to certainly remember
Darren Davis
Curry splits the defense behind the back
fires a three oh
[Applause]
the defense forced eight turnovers in
that third but this was certainly the
Highlight pluck of the day Stephen Curry
knocks down the three the Warriors
outscored them 30 to 18. Steve Kerr
can't believe it but he's seen it night
in a night out this presentation of the
NBA Sunday showcase rebounds taken by
Iguodala
they do have a timeout decide not to use
a curry way downtown bang bang
oh what a from Curry
with six tenths of a second remaining
press up
Roberson just a little late but that's
just
I mean that's about 35 feet out well
beyond the 28th foot mark
off the rim Curry has time three seconds
Curry from half court
[Applause]
that would give them that's a nice
one-two combination two two ball
handlers two attackers
[Applause]
NBA season high and threes made
Curry crossover three-pointer
scratch the game plan Auto finishing
results of going to Durant and Curry
sends Nene no no knocks down the shot
through that dance spectacular execution
putting the hands the ball in the hands
of Curry against Nene and he delivers
and people say why was he in there well
they had given up two offensive rebounds
Tesco was a mismatch on the smaller
Lowry
how about that
Curry
see we can't call this desperation shots
from him because he can make them right
a 35-footer for curry
man Steph just Steph is running into the
front Force Draymond finds him another
three
two
62. and he actually surpasses his buddy
Clay Thompson they're looking for a dude
Draymond Green of course his boy where's
he at where's he at handoff that is a
tough shot too Gary Trent right at him
[Music]
there's that cross screen to get into
Wiggins Steph three
the NBA three-point History Stephen
Curry stands alone as the most dominant
distance shooter the game has ever seen
[Applause]
2974 threes and Counting
Ford picks up Curry
forces to the tough shot which of course
he makes
unbelievable that's what the with the
crazy circus shot out of your frame it
was so high yeah yeah
yeah
wow